let's go next - where do we want to go
let's go to our caller from the 8th 1/3
area code who's calling today from 8 1 3
hello yeah that's you oh hey David
listen I'm AJ I'm calling in Florida and
I was wondering do you think there are
any in terms of like conservative news
outlets do you think they're any outlets
that are actually legitimate in the in
the sense that they get their facts
right and they actually report on things
that matter oh man I don't know I get
asked this question often and it's
usually you know it's like okay I can I
can name some places like okay the Wall
Street Journal is conservative
editorially it's just a basic corporate
media outlet under the umbrella of News
Corporation so it's like do I want to be
promoting them I mean you know their
news reporting side generally speaking
is doing news reporting that is
factually pretty accurate although I
disagree with their editorial
conclusions it's just difficult because
it's like what am I really saying by
saying you can trust the Wall Street
Journal it's like you can trust them to
get some basic facts right in a very
general sense but do I want to be going
around promoting The Wall Street Journal
I mean just another corporate media
outlet under the the News Corporation
umbrella so I don't know I always
hesitate to like list outlets but
there's lots of right leaning media
outlets that are doing basically regular
news reporting and you can trust on a
general level that they're not going to
be very wrong about the facts hmm
interesting no I totally agree that yes
taking shoes I mean I used to think that
the National Review was one of those
legitimate sites but because in 2016
they posted an article about how
conservatives should reject reject from
yeah but after he won the election
because they kind of do like a quick 180
I'm like okay I guess you're I'm done
with you well but the thing about you
know the National I when I was thinking
about how to answer your question that
the National Review occurred to me but
my understand I don't read the National
Review frequently other than some
beds here and there aren't they mostly
an opinion it just like a conservative
opinion outlet rather than a news
reporting outlet which we have to
evaluate in a different way I think they
do have some sites their opinion I mean
I guess it kind of depends on like who
you ask
I mean sometimes those they'll post an
article from like Jonah Goldberg who
says things about like how oh no it was
a it was a good thing that this cop who
killed someone was exonerated but that's
not news reporter I'm sorry I may have
misunderstood the question but his
opinion about whether something is good
or bad that that's that's literally an
opinion it's hit with his analysis I
just didn't I thought you were asking
more about on facts and news reporting
who can be trusted but in any case as
you can see it's kind of a minefield
okay all right thanks very much yeah I
appreciate the phone call I'll give it
some thought but you know I'm just not
my priority is not to promote right-wing
media and so that's why I kind of
struggle with it whenever it comes up